[Musik]
im laufe des letzten jahres kam es auf
wichtigen wertschriften märkten in den
usa zu einem ebenso unerwarteten wie
heftigen zusammenbruch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann mich noch erinnern wie lang er
glaubte weiß ich so gut dass ich ein
großer fehler machen wie sich das auto
momentan ohne zu wissen was in 30
sekunden wissen sie was man da sagen
kann ich wollte ich hätte sie in meinem
leben nie getroffen
der verlust ich absolut unglaublich groß
und dass das möglich ist und sich so
erkennen entwickeln
das musst du die geschichte der bank
bekommen sie drei banken haben mehr oder
weniger ihre ganze seiten kapital
verloren oder mindestens zwei davon
die ubs ist eine die andere und
citigroup ist in einer ziemlich
ähnlichen lage
[Musik]
wir sind da etwas nicht gut gemacht
es ist vom foto geschwindigkeit von muss
breiter ebene markmann sicher sie wollen
und haben in ihrer karriere etliche
wegen der krise auf dem amerikanischen
immobilienmarkt musste die ubs bisher 40
milliarden franken abschreiben
weitere abschreibe sind wahrscheinlich
lieber maßen
du hast diese bank über jahre hinweg zum
erfolg geführt
in den letzten monaten sonst ein
lebenswerk in mancherlei hinsicht in
gefahr
dies hat niemanden schmerzliche
getroffen auf dich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verwaltungsratspräsident marcel ospel
tritt zurück
die renommierte großbank in tiefer krise
wie konnte das passieren ein film von
hansjürg zumstein
[Musik]
das jahr 2004
die ubs ist auf erfolgskurs marcel ospel
hat den zusammenschluss bankverein
bankgesellschaft gemeistert entstanden
ist die grösste vermögensverwalterin der
welt
jetzt soll auch ihre investmentbank die
nummer eins werden kündigt marcel ospel
an die aggressive wachstumsstrategie
markiert den beginn des falls die
aufkündigung und sowas ist problematisch
sondern problematisch ist nach was damit
gemacht worden ist dass er im grunde
ehrgeiz und teilweise ohne die richtige
gedanke und richtige
sicherheitsmaßnahmen umgesetzt
der neue verwaltungsratspräsident peter
kurer
sein bericht an die aktionäre der
shareholder report analysiert was die
ubs falsch gemacht hat keine andere
betroffene bank spricht so offen über
die fehler
stamford in der nähe von new york die
ubs investment bank
hier beginnen die amerikanischen händler
die von ost bild verordnete aufholjagd
der handelsraum der so genannte trading
floor erst zu jener zeit bereits der
größte der welt so groß wie zwei
fußballfelder zusammen
in dieser riesigen halle werden später
milliarden in den sand gesetzt
markus kranz heute vermögensverwalter
hat bis ins jahr 2002 die investment
bank der ubs geleitet er kennt die
kultur der händler glauben falsche ziel
vorgeht oder zu aggressive zuvor geht
fast naiv am ein händler das unglaublich
verheerend sie also der handlichkeit
entry druck wenn ich's nicht mache und
wenn die risikoaversion vorsichtig b wer
jetzt sollten die jahren unter umständen
verlieren stellt der konzern chef heißt
damals peter wuffli ein eher
risikoscheue mensch die aggressiven us
händler hätten in belächelt sagen viele
ich arbeite mit marcel ospel seit vielen
jahren zusammen wir sind ein sehr
starkes gutes team wir werden uns
ausgezeichnet ergänzen
[Applaus]
zunächst alt konzernchef peter wuffli
von erfolg zu erfolg von rekordgewinn zu
rekordgewinnen das ehrgeizige ziel rückt
näher
[Musik]
mit den morgen und willkommen an diesem
sonnigen tag der sehr schön die guten
nachrichten symbolisiert die wir ihnen
heute kommunizieren
später wird er über menschen wie den
busfahrer john i pad stolper pit kocht
sie dieser zeit in rockland kalifornien
dies ist etwas baufällige haus für
stolze 430.000 dollar
was ich an meinem haus am meisten liebe
ist dass es frei steht der vermittler
offerierte alles die finanzierung das
haus alles wurde von der gleichen firma
angeboten
sie machten eine kreditprüfung und
sagten mir großartig du bist 100%
kreditwürdig
busfahrer pitt verdient 4000 dollar im
monat
basierend auf meinem einkommen sagten
sie erhältst du 450.000 dollar kredit j
erhalten damals hunderttausende von
amerikanern ganz leicht über die kredite
es sind sogenannte subprime hypotheken
minderwertigen hypotheken an schuldner
mit höherem risiko
denn
die ubs in den usa die grossbank
beschäftigt hier rund 30.000 personen
das sind mehr als in der schweiz
die aufholjagd läuft doch plötzlich ist
das ziel die investmentbank nummer eins
zu werden
gefährdet die amerikanischen top manager
drohen mit dem abgang
das ist sie sehr betrübt zu hedgefonds
über quasselt sehen will
für die ent und weniger heimische
schaffen und dann einmal gesagt um das
ganze noch forcieren und interlaken
zehnter november 2005 casino kursaal das
kader der ubs trifft sich auf dem
programm ein vortrag über eine neue idee
ein hedge fonds genannt dillon read
capital management
praktisch ein casino innerhalb der bank
hoch spekulative anlagen damit eine
gruppe von händlern nicht abspringt
geführt mit der investment bank wechseln
zum ubs hedge fonds auch der chef john
costas von demis du dieses fernsehbild
vom weltwirtschaftsforum davos gibt
costas nimmt rund 120 ubs händler aus
der investment bank mit die meisten
kommen aus der abteilung für
festverzinsliche anlagen genannt fixed
income marcel ospel zusammen mit luke
mann handelt arnold war kurze zeit
konzernchef der ubs
der vorgänger von peter wuffli
heute repräsentiert erneut eine
investorengruppe die trotzdem ubs
verlusten im großen stil aktien kaufte
von früheren kollegen in der ubs weiß
ich dass viele mit der gründung des
dillon read hedgefonds nicht
einverstanden waren
und wenn sie die heutigen probleme
betrachten so begann diese tatsächlich
damit das große interne ressourcen
eingesetzt wurden um diesen match form
zu realisieren dass ich doch als er in
erstaunliche struktur sieht also quasi
der investmentbanking hält mit dem fixed
income hat und der 120 ps toyota ein
völlig unabhängiges auch näher
betrachten durfte wo sie selber
finanziell unglaublich viel der woche
profitieren das hat doch die talente aus
fixed income wollten zum hedge fonds
gehen denn in der investment bank können
sie viel verdienen aber im hedge fonds
gibt es noch viel mehr geld wenn er
beläuft es gab also große anreize
dorthin zu gehen
und sowieso die meisten wollten mit den
erfolgreichen zusammen sein
das ergebnis war die fixed income
abteilung eine der drei wichtigen
abteilungen der investmentbank wurde
richtiggehend ausgehöhlt und das
wiederum hatte zur folge dass dort
entscheidendes wissen fehlte und zwar
bezüglich handel und risikokontrolle
2006 das entscheidende jahr
john costas beginnt mit seinem neuen ubs
hedgefonds in den immobilienmarkt zu
investieren
auch die abteilung fixed income in der
investment bank steigt eine art
nachahmer strategie jedoch ohne
genügende risikokontrolle
[Musik]
die leute die bei der investmentbank
zurückblieben sahen ihre ehemaligen
kollegen beim hedge fonds investierten
sie entschieden dass sie auch
erfolgreiche händler sein wollten und
begannen jedenfalls sind viele gleiche
bereiche zu investieren oder zumindest
in jenen immobilienmarkt wie ihre
kollegen nun beim hedge fonds strategie
und der ehrgeiz so umgesetzt dass sein
vorstoß bremsen
die händler im ausgehöhlten fixed income
bereich stehen unter erfolgsdruck
sie müssen damit sie aus pilz ziel
erreichen hohe renditen erwirtschaften
deshalb investieren sie noch mehr als
john costas sie glauben dieser prime
papiere seien ebenso sicher wie
applikationen diese normalerweise kaufen
doch ubs intern sind die risiken bekannt
der ökonom bert capella war damals
referent an an der tagung sein vorredner
hieß klaus wellershoff ubs chefökonom
ausgerechnet der ubs mann warnte damals
vor dem überhitzten us immobilienmarkt
ein jahr vor ausbruch der krise
natürlich volkswirtschaft argumentiert
das dauernde bestehende hausbesitzer in
amerika in dem set optiken der wert für
ihre häuser um münze die neue hypotheken
und der nahverkehr ihr auto das rein
entwicklungsgesellschaft aussicht
gewarnt es werde in amerika zum
stillstand vor der ausgabe front row vor
der auf konjunktur und insofern für
andere beobachter ist das irgendwie
ataxie tatsächlich realisiert supreme
schuldner jeanette zu dieser zeit dass
er bald seinem
die k zins nicht mehr witze an kann wie
viele andere amerikaner hat er auf
steigende häuserpreise gehofft damit er
mit einer neuen hypothek die zinsen der
alten zahlen kann
doch jetzt sinken die häuserpreise der
traum vom eigenen heim schwindet
gartenarbeit ist der einfachste teil den
arbeiten die ich erledigen muss aber
alles hängt von meiner hypothek von
neuen zins jetzt liegt der ball bei
meiner bank
sie hat die boutique gewährt ich habe
genug bezahlt ich kann mir nicht leisten
mehr zu bezahlen
johnny pitt hat sich verrechnet wie
viele andere sein schuldner auch und die
ursache beginnt hier bei jim erst einer
von vielen brokern die hypotheken
vergeben und die broker habe man immer
ärmere schichten vermittelt
es trifft zu
wir werden für jede vermittelte hypothek
bezahlen
es braucht also eine gewisse charakter
stärke einem interessenten zu sagen ich
finde es ist nicht in seinem interesse
klasse hypothek aufzunehmen
denn wenn ich das sage er hatte ich
keine provision
wem aber das schicksal des kunden egal
ist hat jede möglichkeit hypotheken zu
vermitteln die hypothek in amerika siehe
foto bsg werden sollen von lokaler
verantwortung der banken
und ja immer einfach redet um für immer
riesige vollere objekt die banken
händlers denn probiert da anleger aller
welt zu hause dazu bündeln sie hunderte
von subprime hypotheken zu wertpapieren
wer sie kauft erhält viel zins das
risiko dahinter liegt beim käufer
beispielsweise einer investmentbank
der broker polterte krediten dezember
verkauften anderen anderen bank die ihr
geht's vielleicht wieder schluss ist es
bei der ubs
die pakete mit die bank oft nochmals mit
anderen risiken und schnürt sie zu neuen
papieren zu sogenannten cds geprüft mit
mathematischen risikomodellen erhalten
sie das qualitätssiegel triple aber was
sie genau enthalten weiß jetzt kaum mehr
jemand diese papiere sind weit entfernt
vom ursprünglichen hypothekarschuldner
sie sind mehrere stufen entfernt das ist
auch der grund weshalb sie so schwierig
zu bewerten und so schwierig zu handeln
sind die aggressiver das hypotheken
programm in den letzten fünf sechs
jahren wurde um so mehr möglichkeiten
hatten wir bürger eine hypothek an
jemanden zu vermitteln
der wirklich nicht geeignet war der
große schwierigkeiten hatte den zins zu
bezahlen
und so konnten auch diejenigen die nicht
qualifiziert waren eine hypothek
gehalten
[Musik]
ich hätte die bank in amerika nicht nur
ihre abstrakte mathematische
risikomodell alu hülle sondern richten
da irgendein auch lässig der vorort von
cleveland laufe untere mittelschicht
familien wohnten wo aber 100 us-dollar
pro holz aus schweizer sicht brauche in
südrussland worden sind und in ordnung
oder eine elegante wall-street-bank die
große paket verpackt worden sind um
verkauft worden sind
[Musik]
hunderttausende von amerikanern sitzen
jetzt auch viel zu hohen hypotheken
sie können ihre steigenden zinsen kaum
bezahlen
die angeblich sicheren subprime pakete
enthalten den wahrheit hochrisiko
papiere
doch werfen die papiere millionen an
zinseinnahmen ab
und sogar peter wuffli erneut
rekordzahlen vermelden
der aktienkurs steigt und steigt der
amerikanischen ubs händler investieren
immer mehr milliarden
in dieser prime papiere dank steigenden
zinseinnahmen rückt die ubs ihrem ziel
investmentbank nummer eins zu werden
näher
die bilanzsumme der ubs wächst und
wächst auf umgerechnet 3 franken
eigenkapital kommen rund 97 runden
fremdkapital damals immer wieder
diskussionen kreuz größe von der bilanz
skeptisch sehen wir uns jetzt groß
seit dem bruch mit noel winters anders
manager das sind sehr extensiv und auch
heftige diskussion xi und blüten sehr
unterschiedliche mining corp
hans geiger ist professor am banken
institut der universität zürich eine zu
große bilanz sehr gefährlich sagte er
insbesondere wenn die darin enthaltenen
handelsbestände das eigenkapital massiv
übersteigen
ubs hat man die 2006 hat sie über 800
wandelt 900 milliarden autos bestand
dass ich oft erlebt dass ich das hier
ausgeht vor bezeichnen und der betrag
ist integriert zum eigenkapital enorm
das ist 20 mal und das ich sehr förmlich
philipp hildebrand vizepräsident der
schweizerischen nationalbank
er schrieb bereits vor ausbruch der
krise die ubs bilanz sei gefährlich groß
zu nehmen die fokussierung auf wachsende
risikoappetit in der bilanz insbesondere
ehemaliger handel im bereich von
investoren
wir sind damals ja zu sich und sachsen
2010 eine expansionsstrategie das ist
nach kündigte schritte gegen sie und das
bilanzvolumen und oppositions volumen
braucht oder also ein grund noch immer
wieder aufs gleiche thema ruft sorgt als
meine strategie hat man tut die umsätze
und ein thomas tallis richtig umsetzen
oder macht der fall beurteilen
und da sind weg sagt ein führender
bremst und andere und das gleich gemacht
weil mir darum dass grundsätzlich der
risikobasierte hybridmodell die bilanz
studie dass das ein sinnvoller weg ist
das ist ein massiver sehr weit
verbreitet ist und der stube sie keine
ahnung wie es in einer einmaligen
situation alle banken mehr oder weniger
sind auf dem berg sieht ubs hat einfach
das vertrauen die risikomodelle vor
allem banken am meisten ausgereizt und
und ich glaube dass er klar wieso das
musst du bist letztlich am meisten
betroffen ist praktisch mindestens
relativ zu anderen großen
internationalen banken tragen
hier sind pessimistisch sieht ausmaß und
sind optimistisch die optimisten
damals gehörten das ist im rückblick
falsch jahreswechsel 2007 wenige wochen
später am 17 februar über sieht die ubs
nochmals ein warnsignal der
hypothekenanbieter new century und die
großbank hsbc informieren über
gewinneinbrüche wegen des us
immobilienmarktes
sechs tage später kommt peter wuffli
erneut die treppe hoch wiederum
rekordergebnisse das ziel nummer eins so
ausblicks vorgabe muss im nächsten jahr
erreicht werden
das jahr hat gut begonnen wir haben eine
gefüllte pipeline allein über das letzte
wochenende haben wir 25 milliarden in
indien in zwei großen transaktionen
beraten dürfen das gefühl der investoren
ist gut gut gelaunt nimmt der damalige
verwaltungsratspräsident marcel ospel
wenige wochen später an einer
versteigerung teil
[Musik]
schönes bild und freu mich drüber und
man erfreut darüber dass sie die
beschäftigen bis graz kultur ein jahr
später werden in den usa die straßen so
aussehen
immer mehr schuldner müssen ihre häuser
verlassen
die ubs glaubt damals sie sei davon
nicht betroffen denn ihre immobilien
wertpapiere seien von höchster qualität
so genannte triple lockt sie das
kontrollinstrument im rückblick note
ausreichend
sie sind die einsicht auch zu stark auf
die ratings system verloren und dann
gesagt das sind positionen betrieb ley
hand um das ist im rückblick am freitag
75 training an geschichte sondern aus
meiner sicht insbesondere also sagen
dass die ratings für sich ausreichend
sind und dass man frei zu gestalten und
so investieren bei der ubs in stamford
die händler weiter
in die angeblich sicheren papiere den
ausstieg anderer banken aus diesem markt
sehen sie als zusätzliche gewinnchance
deshalb wird die bank später so viel
verlieren
kurz vor platzen der blase kaufen die
amerikanischen ubs händler nochmals im
großen stil neue papiere so kuras
bericht an die aktionäre mehrheit eine
explizite strategie fahren im prinzip
später verschoss 79 ist risiko zu hören
zu einem zeitpunkt wo andere banken teil
des bereits im bestand als ein papiere
abgestoßen
damals erst einmal knolle krieg sie wer
hat hier noch eine verkaufen
es ist aus dem moment insbesondere im
mai wo andere große internationale bank
habe steinar verkauft und am markt und
du wirst das praktische über neuheiten
der strategie vom risiko verfahren
es ist schwierig zu verstehen ja es ist
richtig dass zu dieser zeit einige der
wichtigen investmentbanken bereits aus
dem markt ausstiegen um die re
positionen reduzierten die ubs jedoch
machte das gegenteil
ich kenne den brief wendet ihr paket
oder anderer banken erwartet im zweiten
quartal zu tun sie und sie forsch
angekündigt in der bank andere bahn kein
trainer wäre also welches appetit xii
sie hofft die beute stürzen und das ist
natürlich auch im nachhinein ex post
es scheint dass sie damals noch nicht
verstanden hatten
wie und in welchen bereichen sie
engagiert waren deshalb realisierten sie
auch nicht wie hoch sie
us-immobilienmarkt exponiert waren
im april 2007 diskutiert konzernchef
peter wuffli so der aktionärs bericht
mit marcel ospel das große
bilanzwachstum doch beide erachten
sofortmaßnahmen als nicht notwendig
henry druck auf die stufe von der
geschäftsleitung für die investmentbank
immer genau wissen was läuft geschweige
in zürich in group executive board
begrüßte traders in new york und lohnt
und leistung der verwaltungsrat ist
schätzungsweise 20 milliarden schweizer
franken investieren die amerikanischen
händler zusätzlich in dieser kritischen
zeit so die berechnung des schweizer
fernsehens der bestand an subprime
papieren steigt von 40 milliarden ende 0
6 auf rund 60 milliarden ende juni 2007
peter kurer will explizit zu den zahlen
keine stellung nehmen
aber er bestätigt dass die händler im
ersten halbjahr 2007 noch massiv
subprime papiere zu kaufen also mit
seiner kraft und eine direkte theke
sondern wir sehen endlich komplett die
werk schriften um die derivativen bauer
modeindustrie verbrieften instrument das
wir sind sehr indirekt sie den strand
sind tages gemischt mit anderen
komponenten und die sind rebecca romijn
gefühlt das sind allein wo zwar an
bezügen zu dem immobilienbereich
direktem immobilienbereich und darum ist
das ein anderer macht und der witz ist
anders verhalten
ubs zürich opfikon sogar hier wenige
kilometer vom konzernsitz entfernt
lagerten in der liquiditäts abteilung
milliarden von immobilienpapieren hier
wird der tägliche geldbedarf gesteuert
es ist das herz der bank
die abteilung legte früher teilweise in
japanischen staatsanleihen an
dann entschied die ubs das geld
umzuschichten in papiere die große teile
an amerikanischen hypotheken enthielten
vorschlägen wie in ironie vom
risikokontrolle risiken einer
alternative gesucht und geschäfte in dem
bereich sicherheit und er ist noch immer
realität das ist über die
immobilienpapiere informiert die
liquiditäts abteilung die ubs spitze
regelmässig das ist zentral für eine
bank
offensichtlich erkennen die ubs-spitze
damals die brisanz der anlagen nicht sie
glaubt die gelder seien sicher
[Musik]
jahrespressekonferenz der
eidgenössischen bankenaufsicht im april
der direktor der aufsichtskommission
enthüllt wie die ubs damals im märz 2007
die risiken völlig falsch einschätzte
wir haben im winter vor einem jahr hat
man fragen der stirbt nach der
exposition und erhielt von der ubs
anfang märz diese beruhigende antwort
dass sie voll abgesichert ja sogar über
abgesichert zeigen also short
das hat sich dann im nachhinein aus so
ziemlich als auch unbewusst falsch
herausgestellt in dem die band nicht
alle risiken richtig erfasst hatte und
ihre absicherungen in der ages massiv
überschätzt so nietiedt kann zu dieser
zeit seine zinsen kaum mehr bezahlen
erst am ende und aus seiner
nachbarschaft immer mehr häuser stehen
leer
robertino
[Musik]
mein größtes projekt ist jetzt die
zinsen in den griff zu kriegen damit
dieser alligator und nicht mal ein
kommend frist jetzt zahle ich 75 prozent
meines lohns und bald werden es über 100
prozent sein
inzwischen gibt es auch bei der ubs das
erste subprime opfer den hedgefonds die
asien von john costas am dritten mai
2007 wird der hedgefonds die rcm
geschlossen
costas hat sich am seil markt
verspekuliert laut aktionärs bericht
damals ein verlust von 145 millionen
franken
konzernchef peter wuffli wird erstmals
intern und extern kritisiert valencia 28
juni der verwaltungsrat der ubs trifft
sich der aktienkurs ist auf rekordhöhe
man genießt den spektakulären america's
cup die schweizer yacht alinghi gegen
das neuseeländische team
die von der ubs gesponsert alinghi ist
auf siegeskurs
[Musik]
in der anschließenden sitzung stützen
die verwaltungsräte nochmals
ausdrücklich marcel ospels
wachstumsstrategie von drohender
subprime krise kein wort semir und ist
der verwaltungsrat ausgegangen dass wir
super audio hand um es in alter
fußgänger dass man trotz zweier werden
wir sind insgesamt 30 sie wird umso
überraschender der nächste entscheid
peter wuffli wird in valencia durch
marcel rohner ersetzt ein rätselhaftes
sturz war der hedgefonds der grund die
ubs spricht von einem
generationenwechsel hat der abgang wie
sehr überrascht öffentlichkeit hat auf
der jährige glaube da wo der heilige
sind daher sehr glaubwürdig sich merken
wenn jetzt die generation erwachsen die
generaldirektion i leitet wenig der ruf
des jugendrechts geben also was es da
für generationenwechsel das mache die
großen sie ihre weg sagt das ist
[Musik]
nachfolgeregelung nachfolgeregelung spox
sie das heim ihre seit ich bin heute weg
sich kommt aber nur fonds post
verwaltungsrat der weiteren
öffentlichkeit einfach stimmt damals
wurde der anschein erweckt es habe mehr
mit nachfolge der mit risiken zu tun
im rückblick kann man das anders
interpretieren
eines aber scheint mir klar peter wuffli
hatte weder die autorität den hedgefonds
die auf sie ihm aufzubauen noch jene
milliarden von dollar dorthin zu
verschieben aus er hatte auch nicht die
autorität wichtige änderungen am
geschäftsmodell der investment bank
vorzunehmen
später besaß diese autorität nicht
zu wenig autorität und damit nicht das
format verwaltungsrats präsident zu
werden
die spekulationen bleiben unbeantwortet
peter wuffli will keine auskunft geben
in valencia verabschiedet sich die
ubs-spitze in den sommerurlaub 2010 bank
in der guten situation ist mit angst
dass sie an geschichte ist sehr
unangenehme geschichte sich das gefühl
kommen mehr als zwei fehler gemacht wie
man hier sozusagen gründet hand und
operationssaal umgekehrt gefunden und
aus im übrigen anrufe von aktionär und
fotograf dass man eigentlich den rost
kommt hin und dass züge dazu kocht im
heer strom amt und haben einen das
gefühl das ist rundum gekriegt aber der
transaktion kommen zehn viel geld
verdienen
so unternahmen schmiedemeister bereich
ist sehr offen sind der zuversichtlich
stimmen bekommen
am nächsten tag dem 29 juni beginnt die
finanzkrise
auslöser ist die bank bear stearns
sie muss massenhafter planwert schriften
verkaufen weil zwei ihrer hedgefonds
probleme haben
die verkaufswelle lässt die preise für
subprime papiere zusammenbrechen das hat
sehr abrupt angefangen und das ist ja
auch möglich per fähre letzter tag auf
der terrasse und plötzlich vor ca und
das bild seiner schönen die dynamik vor
der krise
es war mir ganz gut und alle die
notenbank unterschätzten dass die
vehemenz vor dem ganzen system und wie
schnell dass sie versucht bereitet hätte
sowohl regional so global wie auch in
verschiedene marktsegmente geldmarkt an
die märkte
ein jahr später wird marcel ospel die
krise folgendermaßen schildern die
marktrisiken veränderten sich in
kürzester zeit in einem horrenden in
diesem ausmaß niemals zu erwarteten
tempo auch erfahrene markt experten
sprechen von der vielleicht
schwierigsten phase für die
finanzwirtschaft seit dem börsencrash
von 1929 und die ubs ist mittendrin
sie sitzt auf subprime papieren im wert
von rund 60 milliarden franken mehr als
das eigenkapital sechster august 2007
die erste von vielen krisensitzungen
[Musik]
das weiß ich zu verfangen intensiv auf
ein größeres politiker sehen und rund um
die eu geschafft und das fest verlassen
muss machen meint allerdings noch nix
das ist die ganz große krise ist das
würde ich meine stehen ein trainer ist
in dem im september den eigentlich nur
aus dem weg ganz komisch ich denke sie
war es die dritte profi toren in 14
tagen die erste gewinn noch dominiert
das positive
es läuft gut bei der größten bank der
schweiz der ubs 79 prozent mehr gewinn
meldet die bank
marcel rohners profit warnung an diesem
tag geht fast unter
anderthalb monate später der erste
abschreiben
seite 4 milliarden franken muss die
erfolgsverwöhnte ubs abschreiben weil
sie sich auf dem amerikanischen
hypothekenmarkt verspekuliert hat
wiederum einen monat später die nächste
gewinnwarnung
es ist enttäuschend so hat der
konzernchef der ubs marcel rohner heute
das quartalsergebnis einer bank
quittiert auf der einen seite gabriel
sicher viel zu sehr auf historische
betrachtungen risikoeinschätzungen
verlassen
auf der anderen seite haben wir die
bilanz zu sehr wachsen lassen
anfangs dezember mit dem nachschub am
ring wirft
fast so groß ist dass das aussieht
machte gott und das mir mein kapital
braucht und kann sie dann sofort auf
besten man glaubt dass man als kapitaler
fehler und das heim in jeder sportart
braucht die ubs findet zwei neue
investoren die 13 milliarden franken
kapital einschiessen
gleichzeitig gibt sie weitere
abschreibungen bekannt die größte
schweizer bank die ubs muss weitere
abschreibungen machen rund 11 milliarden
franken sind es diesmal
ursache ist erneut die us
hypothekenkrise ubs
verwaltungsratspräsident marcel ospel
nimmt dazu erstmals öffentlich stellung
also was wir jetzt gemacht haben dass
das repräsentiert ein absolutes
stressszenario im amerikanischen
immobilienmarkt es sind ja nicht
abschreibungen als realität eine
verluste sind wertberichtigungen
wertberichtigungen also mit blick auf
erwartete verluste im immobilienmarkt
und wir sind sehr sehr weit gegangen ich
kann mir persönlich nicht vorstellen
dass das noch viel schlimmer werden
könnte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wieder liegt marcel ospel falsch die
situation wird noch schlimmer
jetzt legen die zahlen also auf den
tisch und sie sind hat die ubs muss
nochmals 4,3 milliarden abschreiben
insgesamt hat sie jetzt 20 9 milliarden
abgeschrieben und die spirale dreht sich
weiter
es gab eine lange periode in der sich
glaubten sie seien im subprime markt
nicht exponiert langsam kamen alle diese
verschiedenen positionen zum vorschein
und sie merkten dass man das alles
zusammen zählen muss das ergebnis war
eine riesige zahl ich denke diese
prozess brauchte zeit und ich denke sie
glaubten wahrheit zu jedem zeitpunkt das
was sie sagen aber sie hatten noch nicht
alle fakten beisammen und dann zum
ersten april der große schock nochmals
19 milliarden abschreibungen marcel
ospel tritt zurück
besiegelt haben den abschied des
mächtigsten borghees des landes die
neuesten ab schreiber welche die ubs
heute bekannt geben musste
mit den zusätzlichen 19 milliarden sind
die abschreibungen im april auf total 40
milliarden angestiegen
ich bin überzeugt persönlich dass wir
mit diesen maßnahmen jetzt dieses
problem eben amerikanischen
immobilienmarkt hinter uns bringen
können
das haben sie letztes mal auch gesagt
dass die neuen abschreiben bekannt
wurden
wir haben das letzte mal nicht in dem
ausmaß also mit dieser aggressivität
wertberichtigt wie jetzt in dieser um
die entsetzlich so viel geld verliere so
viel furcht vor vergangenen jahrzehnt
verloren und es ist sicher bitter war es
zu tage tritt fehlen der risikovorsorge
langsame reaktionen bank sehen dass sie
natürlich den städten hohes wo mehrere
halten
der verlust ist absolut von glaube und
riesengroß und dass das möglich ist und
sich so ihr können entwickeln
das musst du die geschichte durch
bankdrücken es muss wieder ebene
sinnvoll passiert fallen
der oberste verantwortliche marcel ospel
er verzichtet auf den bonus für das jahr
aber in den jahren zuvor hatte er
millionen an boni erhalten
ich finde bonus fürs versagen ist immer
falsch und es ist ebenfalls falsch wenn
heute leute sagen ich habe für dieses
jahr auf den bonus verzichtet diese
leute vergessen dass die boni erhielten
für das geschäften in den letzten fünf
jahren in denen eigentlich die heutigen
probleme verursacht wurde verantwortlich
auch peter wuffli
er ließ zu dass die händler praktisch
ohne lee mieten subprime papiere kaufen
konnten
verantwortliche auch der amerikaner
jenkins der sich die strategie ausdachte
und clive standish der den händler das
geld zur verfügung stellte ihre verträge
sind aufgelöst
das erhalten total 94 millionen franken
davon 30 millionen bonuszahlungen für
die aktive zeit bei der ubs für die
frist für kündigungs tor und assist und
das führt nach rheda sprachlich zu denen
rote zahlen
seit ich die es eben auch wieder
erschienen wo es am meisten erhielt
offenbar john costas chef des
geschlossenen hedgefonds dillon read
capital management
das war vor augen die leistung bringt
wahnsinnig uhr zahlt und ich glaubte
sich der heutige situation notwendige
ich kann sagen dass ich nicht fair das
ist schon klar dass er 20 30 millionen
verdient das ist betrachtet die andere
betrachte ich die rallye teil wie es
manche tauchen wahnsinnsquote job wohl
nicht sehr großes problem haben und das
absolut unzulässige erachte ich steht wo
mit enorm viel geld obwohl sie enorme
schaden angerichtet hat und das ist
meines erachtens situation zusammen mit
vielen read capital management
was ihr fehlt stört dass john costas mit
groß auch wenn die bücher gegangen ich
mir sogar
180 millionen dollar kassierte dass es
wirklich was sagen ich dem spezifische
form ist das ist richtig dass man am
schluss gemacht hat
aber der vertrag ist aber dass sie das
mir möglichkeit content die ganze über
nacht schließen und das ist froh es
immer ganz unwichtigen erspart
[Musik]
hauseigentümer johnny pitt ist
verschwunden
das telefon ausgeschaltet er ist wie
viele andere ein opfer der subprime
krise geworden
[Musik]
zeit
nicht gut
[Applaus]
es liegt
sehr geehrte damen und herren geschätzte
aktionärinnen und aktionäre
besten dank für das vertrauen und die
woche
ok
peter kurer hat jetzt die schwierige
aufgabe die aktionäre und die kunden zu
überzeugen
wie gesagt ich betrachte dies persönlich
als verpflichtung die bank auf den
erfolgspfad zurückzuführen
du wirst überhaupt natürlich das ist
auch bestand aber du bist wir ganz
einander über und sie wird sich ka
ambitionen mehr erfüllten die
investmentbanken sie sie wird alles
dafür tun zu mir die führende position
im privatkundengeschäft verteidiger
verwaltungsrat und konzernleitung sieht
sich einigen und hegen nicht den
geringsten zweifel dass wir
veränderungen vornehmen müssen
tiefgreifende veränderungen in bezug auf
die art und weise wie wir mit risiken
umzugehen haben
wäsche look wenn sie es in einem
größeren zusammenhang betrachten dann
ist es so dass der marktwert der ubs
wieder zurückgefahren ist auf jenen von
1998 zehn jahre zurück also alles was
erreicht wurde ist wieder verloren
die schließt insbesondere die
überprüfung der gestoppt und form unsere
investment bank sowie eine klare
eingrenzung des risiko bedingtes unseres
unternehmens ein
die bank nur sich widerruf kunden
fokussieren das biwak wo größer waren
sie in den westen ein kind prozess und
auch im privaten ist und sie wieder
morgen klar werden der wert von der bank
ist dass conti chefs wollen drei mit
bereichen
wir haben leisten
zuallererst haben wir uns darauf
festgelegt unsere einzigartige position
im vermögensverwaltungsgeschäft sowie
unsere ubs marke zu schützen und
weiterzuentwickeln
hier müssen wir hart arbeiten um unsere
reputation und das vertrauen unserer
kunden und investoren unserer
mitarbeiter und unserer
aufsichtsbehörden rasch zurückzugewinnen
und neu zu franken
das bistum einer durchaus vertretbare
neuanfang wo aber er muss seine bewährte
zeige bv generelles vertrauen sich aber
weigert andere große operateure die
interesse aller märz wieder voll
hergestellt ist
in meiner neuen rolle wollte ich mich an
die worte basterds ist wenn er sagt
entschlossenheit im unglück ist der
halbe weg zur rettung
ich danke ihnen in den nächsten wochen
muss die ubs wohl weitere abschreiber
vornehmen
noch ist sie nicht über den berg noch
ist die finanzkrise nicht ausgestanden